pierre olivier pineau merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors
d'abord pour bien se rendre compte qu
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter
l'état actuel du secteur pétrolier au
canada combien d'emplois il représente
quelle part il adore l'économie du pays
alors le canada comme vous l'avez
mentionné le quatrième plus gros
producteurs de pétrole au monde c'est
une position qui a augmenté ces
dernières années parce qu'on était plus
le dixième producteur il ya une dizaine
d'années mais la production est vraiment
concentré en alberta qui une province de
l'ouest canadien
une petite province avec autour de 1 ou
2 millions d'habitants
et c'est là que l'essentiel de la
production se fait surtout de la vie sud
et est du des sables bitumineux c'est du
pétrole issu des sables bitumineux un
pétrole qui coûte très cher à l'échelle
canadienne
le secteur de l'énergie représente
environ 5% du pib mais en alberta c'est
25% du pib qui centrée sur le secteur de
l'énergie
donc pour cette promesse là c'est
extrêmement tragique l'effondrement du
cours du pétrole
alors par quel mécanisme justement ce
secteur pétrolier a été touchée aussi
durement pendant le procès durement par
la pandémie et pardon donc c'est un
secteur qui s'est développée sur la
prémisse que les prix du pétrole restent
très au delà de 100 dollars le baril
puisque jusqu'en 2014 de 2010 à 2014 il
ya eu l'essentiel de l'accroissement de
la production
on prévoyait un baril de pétrole au delà
du 100 $ en 2014 il ya eu la première
crise des prix dans le pétrole la date a
eu très mal ça fait cinq ans que
l'albertain a très mal dans son secteur
pétrolier parce qu'avec des prix de soie
autour de 50 60 dollars le baril
les producteurs font à peine d'argent en
alberta alors c'est évident que depuis
le début de l'année où les prix se sont
effondrés à 22 dollars et même beaucoup
moins dans certains cas parce que
l'alberta est une province enclavée qui
souffrent de manque d'accès à des
marches et donc les prix que les
producteurs albertain touches sont
inférieurs aux prix mondiaux
et donc elle est doublement affecté par
cette crise des prix des prix mondiaux
qui sont bas et une
pas cité à vendre dans des marchés
externes l'alberta y captive des états
unis comme marchés externes donc les
producteurs albertains et l'essentiel
des producteurs canadiens sont
extrêmement touchées comme vous l'avez
mentionné il perd des milliards de
dollars ils font des mises à pied
massives c'est un secteur qui va
difficilement pouvoir récupérer de cette
crise alors justement est ce qu'on est
en train d'assister à la fin de la
production du pétrole au canada alors
n'ont évidemment pas parce qu'un il ya
des infrastructures qui sont en place
qui vont permettre une fois la crise
passée de reprendre une production
intérêts qu'on la connaissait dans les
années précédentes
évidemment le modèle de croissance qu'a
connue la production canadienne ces
dernières années ne pourra plus se
maintenir
parce qu il est bien évident que le
secteur pétrolier mondial ne va plus
connaître des prix soutenus
helvea pendant de longues périodes avec
la lutte aux changements climatiques
valeur il va falloir faire des
changements et l'alberta doit se
préparer à ces changements
justement comme changement pour conclure
il ya la chef des verts elizabeth may et
le chef bloquiste jean yves françois
blanchet est ils ont plaidé pour que les
fonds fédéraux ne soit plus injecter
dans les projets pétroliers mais plus
dans ceux axés sur les énergies
renouvelables
c'est vers cette solution que l'on se
dirige au canada alors c'est difficile
de dire que ça va être cette solution là
parce que l'importance de l'industrie
des hydrocarbures et quand même grande
donc il va falloir continuer à la
soutenir d'autant plus que les canadiens
sont de très gros consommateurs de
pétrole et de gaz naturel
donc on ne peut pas simplement dire on
se tourne vers les énergies
renouvelables au niveau de la production
il faut changer notre consommation c'est
le principal défi que le secteur
énergétique confronte aujourd'hui au
canada
merci beaucoup pierre olivier pineau
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur à hec
montréal
dans le domaine de la gestion du secteur
énergie